you do willing graces in front of a live
audience like this yes like this and you
I mean the audience's you can tell
there's such a great energy there
they're so happy to see you guys back
together what do you guys do to prepare
to get in front of the audience you know
like this everyone has different rituals
I bathed in whole fat milk
yes just before I come out here but
sorry I walked in on that yeah that's oh
no I invited you in but not interested
he's intolerant Oh Gloria Allred about
it yeah exactly there'll be a suit but
I'm just curious what did you guys do
anything to to get ready for that we've
always had this tradition that the four
of us get tight you know like like
Madonna and her dancers you know in
truth or dare and we whisper this thing
that we've never told anybody but lately
because of social media now it's got to
be bigger now Megan always wants to do
something for Instagram and she's she
always walks out just before the curtain
goes up and she's like guys do it do it
dance do a woman grace dance and and I'm
I'm too old for this oh I seem to have
only one move which shocks me I twerk I
don't I don't you twerk I don't you
don't you don't to see it it's bad but I
don't know I think we want to see
I know and that's not that's also you
can't use that for I'm old so I'm
standing out I'm thinking about my lines
and I'm thinking and let the curtain
going up Elvis is like do it dad and I
just you can look it up on Instagram
every single one for its like eight
shows now I look at the camera they go
[Applause]
does it look like your torque looks like
you need to have some corrective surgery
like your first night in the strip club
you